alors mesdames messieurs pendant que
elvis et elton réfléchit cependant que
fait paris chez vous que vous tapez sur
votre militaire a tenté lui ça va faire
un an que tu dis pendant que vous tapez
sur votre minitel t'explique même pas
comment on tape sur un minitel explique
je sais pas je pense que tout le monde
sait comment tape sur un militaire doit
ça c'est pas clair non mais comme
apporte un minitel importé moins
militaire voilà tu ouvres ton minitel et
utah prendre six casques bleus et puis
voilà non c'est pas ça je vais te
montrer là tu ta faute tu l'as elton
john qui presse à genève c'est pas un
truc de [ __ ] le minitel il ya un petit
ponton minuteur tu le mets là et tu
tapes ce ton minitel faut qu'il y ait un
droit c'est pas d'espèces protégées le
minitel ça va ça se reproduit et tu
tapes sur ton minutes à la table sur une
minute c'est d'une simplicité exemplaire
que je devrai maintenant leçon
qu'est-ce qu'on écoute sortis à temps
thiery ma fille et a montré et a appris
aujourd'hui comment taper sur le minitel
vrai moi je vais t'apprendre le show
business to business d'abord c'est le
contrat pas très important ok après
c'est un studio pour l'enregistrement du
disque et après il ya le lancement du
disque et pour être sûr de ne rien rater
de l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus